you often talk about getting off this
planet
and i think you don't often talk
about extraterrestrial life intelligent
life
out there do you wonder about this kind
of thing about intelligent civilizations
out there
i do but i try to not wonder about it in
a particular way
um in a certain sense i do find that
speculating about bigfoot in the loch
ness monster and space aliens is kind of
a recreation for when things
aren't going very well at least it gives
us some meaning and purpose in our lives
so i worry about you for example the
simulation hypothesis is taking over
from religion you can't quite believe
enough to go to church or synagogue or
the mosque
on the weekend so then you just take up
an interest in
in the simulation theory because that's
something like what you do for your job
coding
i do think that in some sense the issue
of aliens is a really
interesting one but has been spoiled by
too much sort of
recreational escapism the key question
that i find is let's assume that it is
possible
to look at the night sky and see all of
these distant worlds and then go visit
them
if that is possible it's almost
certainly possible through some
uh as yet un uh unknown or
not accepted theory of physics beyond
einstein
and i mean it doesn't have to be that
way but probably is
if that theory exists there would be a
percentage
of the worlds that have life and sort of
a drake equation kind of a way
that would have encountered the ability
to escape
soon enough after unlocking the power
of the atom at a minimum and whatever
they have that is probably analogous to
the cell
on that world so assuming
that life is a fairly generic thing that
arises
probably not carbon-based probably
doesn't have dna but
that something that fits the pattern of
uh darwinian theory which is
dissent with variation um differential
success
and they're about constantly improving
and so on that they're through
time there will be a trajectory where
there'll be something increasingly
complex and fascinating and beautiful
like us humans but much more
they can also off gas whatever entropy
it creates
to give an illusion that you're
defeating thermodynamics
right so whatever whatever these things
are probably has an analog of the
bilipid layer
so that cells can get rid of the chaos
on one side of the barrier and keep
order on the other
whatever these things are that create
life assuming that there is a theory to
be found that allows
that civilization to diversify
um we would have to imagine that
such a civilization might have taken an
interest
in its concept of the universe and have
come here
they would come here they would have a
deep understanding of the physics of the
universe sufficient to
have arrived here well there's two
questions whether they could arrive
physically and whether they're
information could be sent here
and whether they could gain information
from us it's possible
that they would have a way of looking
into our world without actually reaching
it i don't know
but yes if my hope which is that we can
escape this world
is can be realized if that's if that's
feasible
then you would have to imagine that the
reverse is true and that
somebody else should be here
you